yours to another man
umi yeah okay i start
andy you want to start
he's a little nervous
no give your best to the one you got and
if you can't give him your best and he's
going elsewhere
then you can't blame him
i'm sorry but like i said before no man
no man no woman should probably bad sex
and if a man is having bad sex it's the
woman's fault
it's the woman's fault because if you
get a man a male virgin and a woman
he's gonna have bad sex anyway she's
gonna teach him rubbish just to keep him
down there but if you get a man who's
had lots of sex and a virgin he's gonna
teach everything he knows to make sure
that she can perform properly
so as far as i'm concerned if you are
with somebody and you're not getting
good sex from them
i'm not talking about making that
because women audiences making up making
up that's the little christmas birthdays
whatever minutes when i have sex
if the sex ain't good
get rid because i'm sorry but there's
too many men that they're having sexist
relationships and it's wrong
all these feelings about oh i want their
personality i want this and that why
doesn't that work the other way you said
that the man can teach the virgin woman
how to have good sex but why can't the
woman who's had a lot of sex teach the
virgin how to have this why is it not
well i just i just think if women were
lined up for virgins then one out of
three men wouldn't be virgins wait say
again if women were lined up to date
virgins if that was true then one out of
three men wouldn't be virgins
i don't get it because
okay one out of three men under 30
haven't had sex in the past year or are
virgins one out of every three men
so like if women wanted virgins they're
there
but how would you know
i still don't care and that falls into
that how much confident she was sorry so
that she was talking about earlier with
a man approaching you nobody was talking
earlier and he mentioned confidence that
confidence comes from experience with
women over time so that same confident
guy you want to approach you he's not
going to get that confidence unless he's
had that previous experience including
sexual
so
you won this guy with this low body
count that's not the same sort of guy
confidence like i don't think it's like
just related to sex obviously yeah if
you add
you know multiple women like you had a
lot of experience you're probably going
to be a tiny bit more confident
but i think like you know how do you
acting by this kind of even you know
inside you or you have or not like it's
not really
about how
a man can bring it out of a woman but
how often does a woman bring it out of a
man is that because you're speaking from
a woman's perspective so you wouldn't
know a woman so i can only speak from oh
i had around with men so i i got male
friends
most i say 99 of my friend and male
they're not getting enough sex
and they're not getting enough sex how
they want it where they want it whenever
they want it and it's the women that are
like holding these keys to sex
like
that's why i can speak from a woman
because there's men out there you can as
a woman that's had ex-partners you can
look at your partners and see where the
women have done them wrong
you can know because the women at
teaching them the women are so quick to
open their legs but not their mouth to
say excuse me but mate but what are you
doing down there that's wrong fix up or
this is how you're supposed to do it but
there's too many men there's too many
women out there now having bad sex
because of the men's previous partners
not teaching them properly
[Music]
interesting that's not well i guess i
guess as a girl but how do you know it's
bad
you must have a lot to complete like
pain every night's pass
not running and i'm not shivering they
might be saying about the earthquake no
what i'm saying you have to have a lot
to compare it to to know what's bad
no no you can just know how you feel
because if you go and you relax yourself
and you free up and you trust the man
that he knows what you're doing you're
gonna have good sex all the time
um okay what you want to answer the
question um i mean i personally so like
this might sound controversial but i
feel it's unrealistic to believe a man
should be with one woman
okay so i agree
that you know they shouldn't expect it
from a man but i feel like everything
comes down to control so
as a man if you decide you're going to
go into a relationship you have to
decide to control yourself and choose to
be faithful
well if your woman is a freak
what would that what would that do that
she's up for anything with you sexually
yeah you're still gonna go elsewhere it
doesn't matter you're still gonna go out
swimming if you wanna go elsewhere
you're gonna go you can have the perfect
woman in the world
if you wanna cheat you cheat it doesn't
matter there's i do not believe there is
anything a woman can do to stop a man
from cheating if he wants to cheat
sorry do you agree that not all menchie
hold it down bro
do you agree that not all men should
speak your truth
some men don't
no i'm saying not all men cheat yeah
that's fine then
what one thing i can i i'll go ahead so
one thing i will say is i think men
exercise their options
right so most men
women don't find them attractive and
therefore they don't have options to
exercise
and therefore they cannot cheat whereas
the top percentile of men have options
to exercise therefore they can cheat and
if the woman that is with them
feels a type of way wants to leave
he's like okay
i'll just add a new girl to the rotation
and he's able to get a plethora of girls
because he's got the option to exercise
his world to cheat
yeah no that's fine i just i just don't
believe that all men cheat no there's a
minority that don't i agree i think yeah
but i think you'd agree most do if they
can yeah
yeah if they could but but most men
can't
and mostly [ __ ]
can't what most men in relationships
can't cheat
um
so what about you do you think it's fair
that women expect monogamy if they gave
their best ears to another man ah no um
definitely not definitely not
what would you define as a woman's best
years go ahead okay well i'll put that
into the same sort of especially with
that particular male or man
usually
her child's dad her first love is
usually that type of person
you know he's usually he's usually got
everything else out of her by the time
you've come across her whatever the
scenario is
you are getting the after bits there's
going to be memories of him be it in a
relationship sexual whatever
you know there's going to be especially
if they've got a child there's an
imprint i've seen it loads of times
you know people have broken up they've
got with someone else as soon as the kid
dad come back in the picture
gone they're either sleeping together or
they're back together so
if a woman's had her best years with
another male
[Music]
to me she she's actually his to be
perfectly honest and i found a lot of
the time that
there's that one particular guy
is there a certain age that you would
say
in and around 30 30 ish
midfield it depends what she's kind of
done up to then okay um but to be fair
about sort of like the mid 30ish then by
that point it's like yeah it's a bit
sticky what do you think is it fair to
expect monogamy if you've given your
best years to another man
because because it's like if van if men
value purity and youth and you don't
have that to give to him how can we
expect like monogamy when they can't
fulfill their mating strategy
is this
are you speaking like from a new
relationship or they've been together
for years and now he can cheat because
she's given her best like so so what i'm
saying is relationships are an exchange
and men and women want different things
like we want resources we want together
tall and that can protect you we want
resources protection provisioning guys
want youth purity
peace
and so if they can't fulfill their
mating strategy which is to get a girl
with low